we'll play a little bit of the clip of
these women hitting on name these
you'll talk about it
[Laughter]
I
love it I got this Valentine from you
today
Happy Valentine's Day Liam X and then I
and I was like oh and I find out you
gave it to all of us so let me say
because it's no secret that Joy thinks
you're oh the hottest or the greatest
ever and
few times she brought you up over the
years I think we have some videos I
would just like to have my ashes
sprinkled over Liam Neeson there's room
in my heart for Steve and for Liam
Neeson the main Liam Neeson right now
are those kidnapping movies that he does
yeah I can't sit through this this is
this is like a human rights violation
this is this is I mean you couldn't even
do this to someone at Guantanamo Bay